if a man of Nunes didn't retire we're
barely talking about this fight and it's
not a case of Amanda Nunes not put on a
good performance it's a case of Irene
aldana literally doing nothing she froze
in the moment the moment was too big
that's what's going on there if you look
back at the history of aldana's fights
whenever it became the biggest moment
like the the game-changing fight she
hasn't showed up so there's not a lot
left for Manning this to do she's kind
of waiting around so I think it was the
perfect retirement I think she's
retiring like khabib did where there's
no chance she comes back have to take
like a Ronda Rousey maybe like some
super special get her out of bed but she
sounds like she's done done by far the
best I've ever done no argument there as
far as women goes no argument